l'équipe de france de foot bal effectué
demain soir à naples en match amical
face à l'italie sa première sortie
depuis son élimination de la coupe du
monde depuis nos petits bleus ont dû
bleus à l'âme et ils attendent de leur
nouveau sélectionneur aimé jacquet qu'il
retrouve l'alchimie de la victoire cela
avant les qualifications de l'euro 96
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux yann
lavoix diddy rancoeur c'est une seconde
jeunesse qu'aimé jacquet semble avoir
retrouvé à naples et il n'est pas
possible de se tromper c'est bien lui le
nouveau patron de l'équipe de france
autoritaire mais surtout heureux
il est resté plusieurs années sans
entraîner chômeurs puis adjoint de
gérard houllier bref le terrain lui
manquait c'est ma passion c'est mon job
depuis des années j'ai fait
l'entraînement
je me retrouve totalement dans cette
expression
et puis je dois dire que tout part du
terrain tout part de ce rectangle vert
tous se situe là donc l'entraînement est
très important aimé jacquet soucieux
tout de même parce que commencer sa
nouvelle carrière par un match contre
l'italie c'est un cadeau de bienvenue un
peu empoisonné
en revanche il n'est pas trop inquiet à
l'idée de diriger les meilleurs joueurs
français puisqu'il a eu à bordeaux les
meilleurs des années 80 mais cette fois
il a fait appel à les jeunes des
nouveaux des anciens il y a même des
revenants la difficulté c'est de recréer
un groupe de recréer je dirais un
mouvement un objectif et comme j'ai peu
de temps il faut que j'aille très vite
c'est pour ça que j'ai un flip un peu
plus de jeunes pour pouvoir justement
que crée ce dynamisme avec bordeaux aimé
jacquet a tout gagné sur le plan
national en coupe d'europe
il a échoué de peu contre naples par
exemple qui avait éliminé les girondins
en 89
il possède donc la fameuse expérience
internationale car aimé jacquet sait
aussi que le dernier match de l'équipe
de france en italie s'était déroulée ici
à naples il ya 16 ans presque jour pour
jour
tout réussissait à cette époque à la
bande à hidalgo qui venait il faut dire
d'obtenir son billet pour le mondial
argentin face à la bulgarie